hey guys good morning good afternoon
good evening whatever time it is you
guys are watching this video I am on my
way to get Jenna or I might make her
uber because I'm already late we're on
our way to Vegas you guys never seem to
show the property brothers or I've ever
heard of them we are going to their
house in Vegas to shoot some really fun
videos
you
all right I gave it I told Chet I'll
pick her up Jenna's here October has
arrived I told them previously I might
have made you take an uber if I was
super late but look at it I was
expecting because I just assumed in our
campaign we're a little late we have
carry-on basically I just hop it on the
plane at LAX I don't have a cardigan
902 we Ward in eight minutes it's a
current Starbuck situation
I think we'll make it 9/11 we're
currently boarding that's my name is my
name we made it okay so I told you guys
why we're here we're actually filming
some really a fun collab video what who
are you why am i hail defense in our
house Stewie that's all that matters
Omega cheese
the student likes to roll over a lot
I've noticed he's liked to play with a
little bit the way I just notice right
now that I'm outnumbered it's all J's
right here I'm gonna none j-just wait
outside okay great see I've been trying
to get some furniture and I'm not really
good at designing things so I watched
your show on Netflix of you guys
redesigning this amazing house yeah so I
would just love some inspiration and
give us a little tour so my philosophy
is that your home should feel like you
when you walk into it friends should not
know this is very generic I don't really
get a feeling for who the person is so I
love decorating around conversation
pieces you'll see up top we have a
medieval sword a medieval weapons
collection we've been collecting since
we were kids because we're angry angry
individuals that's why we're married
well if there's a zombie apocalypse you
want to have sort of armor and sword
that if this is in LA if you're doing
some design just like Justine you don't
want to have swords above beds or
anything like that just a little tip but
if you look over here the two cross
swords on the wall with the two shields
and then that big sword that the armor
is holding we bought those those were
the first swords we ever bought when we
were 10 years old in Scotland yeah this
is
the home everything in the home I want
it to be relaxing because we live pretty
chaotic lives so if you live a cat
eclipse I when you're doing all these
things you won't have a place you can
just kick back and relax and just sink
right in so you may be wondering why two
grown dudes live together so we actually
had our own places in big family yeah we
decide we left our bunk beds and missed
them
no we sold our own places we don't get
home a lot our family and friends stay
here more than we do with a guest house
next door which we'll show you for our
parents
but we just thought we call it the Scott
family compound we got one place that
all our friends and family can come to
we have a great after area to hang out
and then every room in the house has a
little something for somebody in our
family I'm gonna give you a sneak peek
of something that I have never shown
anybody your bedroom when it's not made
up that's what it's going to be here
come here
okay you don't judge me because I just
got up so I did not make my bed
amazing preempted only allowed it gets
me the threshold come in I put away all
the dirty underwear and the lazy stuff
in the bedroom I think it's very
important as well that it's very
relaxing you should not be doing work in
the bedroom you should not be doing
things that are kind of crazy chaotic
but I love having about all these little
collectibles from traveling this is a
this is an idol made out of volcanic
rock that I got while I was in Tahiti I
want to show you the most embarrassing
thing that drew never allows me to show
anybody there's drew move your thumb are
you talking about wait oh that's me I
went by Andrew Harry Potter this is
Jonathan over here Jonathan always did
this space so Jonathan has been magician
did matresses he's young every photo
that's his magic Jonathan phase don't
judge my magic face I used to want to be
a magician no I don't have I don't have
any to go perform entertain I can juggle
okay I'm gonna make that work go some
fruit John all right you guys
hey John and Edna I feel like now why
are you guys hanging out of a better you
look - in cool I like your carpets
thank you having some carpet dilemmas
what's the carpet dilemma uh well I
don't measure anything did you say to
measure is your measure most important
thing have you heard the saying don't
measure and then have to remeasure six
times is that you heard that say that
sounds about like certainly something ed
would say it's a friend egg but here's
one thing carpet is sort of a thing of
the past
area rugs are a lot better because you
can move them you can swap them out you
can still protect your floor this is an
area rug okay that's what I met an area
rug so those wall the wall and it's like
stapled in I don't know how messy or
dirty you are is she mastered oh oh yes
lots of things she just threw right
under the bus okay
you can also get what are called carpet
squares and they're basically squares
like a foot a foot square and you put
them together and you can have it all
one cool pattern or you can mix and
match colors and they're so easy to
clean and swap out you can put it in the
dishwasher actually meant for commercial
yeah they're meant for commercial so
they're very very durable we put the
only light will do everything like from
a kid's room on the floor because you
know they're gonna get dirty TV just an
area rug like I can make it look just
like an area rug any size you want so
you don't have to measure so let's just
go for like a bite and I'm like that
sounds good cool so the day but look at
this living room for example if you had
an 8 by 10 rug in this living room it
would look like you were met wearing a
microphone it would be so undersized
that would just be weird so we don't
want any living room speedos doing
custom built-ins is a good idea so you
have a lot of junk and if you can get
messy do some building so you can hide
some of it well also do that Roback jams
right now oh yeah that's John I love the
ocean I love water sports shot shocked
me off I'll do it if we're going to the
game room you have to run
I can't run it you guys I'm injured from
a skateboarding accident actually would
have tripped over that I've put links to
the Thoroughbred for running up and down
this okay alright alright so this little
sign over here this is a tribute we
actually custom designed for my dad my
dad's nickname when he's younger was
lucky and we're in Vegas so we thought
this is a cool little vintage and the
company that made all the old Las Vegas
signs you know the old neon signs yes go
they're the ones who actually made this
for us so so up here this was that bonus
square footage we wanted to try and
maximize the use of every area we had
this as an office before but nowadays
let's be honest nobody has an actual
office for most people unless you're
doing something like if you're editing
or something I have an office don't have
room office so I decided to make this a
game area for the family really oh yeah
yeah so this is our gaming station that
my older brother likes to game and so
little area so again to just your pieces
if you if you look around here actually
you have these side tables here they're
dice everything's a throwback to Vegas
in here but this this little seat over
here
the the pop is different the finish on
these these tables and the console are
different you don't have to make
everything match it actually looks more
like a designer touch if not everything
matches yeah Jenna well giveaways
speaking of not matching what did I do
in the bedroom oh you're the bedroom
it's all whatever it's all TIA I like
this color she was just like yeah like
she wanted to okay we need to have a
sit-down talk here this is an
intervention
yes okay 10 taupe burgundy and all of
these things so 2000 up for the past
that's 90s and early 2000 what do i what
you're reborn in before all right so
basically you've designed your space to
be like the 16 year old you all right
that would've been all pink 16 year old
justine wanted black walls and my mom
would not let me know you were the goth
kid i sort of I might have been I did
not know well you have to have color
that's the one great thing about trends
you know the trend right now color is
back people are enjoying color yeah so
we were getting rid of the tan
getting rid of any of that said we're
gonna give you some personality oh I
screwed up too late let's show you the
view outside a very nice quiet area
there's not a lot of tourists and stuff
around here but a great view you can see
the mountains
oh yeah we're slightly obsessed with
marble but so we have a horse farm next
to us so we always here this is how we
grew up with a ranch on a ranch with us
your horses know that there are
neighbors for us and then you know
there's nothing behind us right now we
can see the mountains and you can have
straight access what you need to put
into your house most important thing is
putting in any house you have to have a
commercial grade water slide so because
I have seen you guys build this from
watching the netbook show
I remember the struggle the struggle the
water there was Astro this struggle was
Jonathan wanted this big childish toy
and it was going to cost us a fortune in
the city already denied it twice because
they'd never put a commercial grade
waterslide into a residential
application and he kept fighting for it
finally I liked the idea that I didn't
want to waste all the money if they
didn't go through
he finally worked his magic and we got
to prove look at these jets good town
this is the most important thing we are
such nerds yeah we installed a clapper
to turn it on and off so who wants to
operate
we're playing a prank on me oh I heard
that someone loves water slides
no I am actually terrified of water
slides I'm always afraid of getting
stuck in like the little you walk you
will not get stuck however I warn you
that 1 in 10 people lose their soup yeah
well I didn't bring one
so see that here this is kind of above
you just to stay down over the river use
the yard
it is getting warm out what questions
questions do you have it okay I want to
get fake grass because my dog just
destroys it and eats everything outside
so where's home in Los Angeles okay so
it doesn't get so crazy hot that you
have to worry about your dogs burning
their feet on artificial turf here it
gets so hot in summer time that we
actually have a special polymer sand
that we put in because the way it works
when you lay it down you have to have
two pounds of sand per square foot on
top of it to hold it down so what I do
is I use a special polymer sand that
absorbs moisture so I'll run my
sprinkling system ie regression system
it'll absorb all that moisture and then
over the next week it'll slowly
evaporate and reduce the surface
temperature by 40 degrees yeah cuz I
don't want to burn his little feet this
is a super cute this is what I told you
to get in your yard a little putting
green and she laughed at me okay but the
dog I don't have this much room though I
mean we very limited one hole you could
do well until enews our Z this is a
Jonathan first if you remember watching
the show Jonathan tried to design the
pudding area first and it was pathetic
yeah well I definitely saw the original
plan for the pudding grain that was
likable careful sister so careful I'm
just saying you know might not been the
best idea but my bedroom is also yeah
you do have another yeah I wanted so I
mean drew doll guys or even it's one one
adults a lot more so that here's the
thing I designed 90% of the house and
drew design 10% and that's already
remember
he says Jonathan has his make-believe
land that he lives in that he does all
the work and he's convinced everyone of
them confirms reality land
hey watch their sled up basketball this
is my area I'm the basketball freak the
sport freak and so I actually feel that
we need to have a competition we are
going to it's gonna be wouldn't play
horse or 21 whatever it is we Pig
shorter I want Jenna on my team yes yes
Jenna is the non-injured you two are
injured yeah yeah so it'll be the IVA I
pulled the tenon of my bicep so I can't
lift my arm up above my head well I felt
really really hard skateboarding two
days ago and I can't really lift either
of my arms like even hurts to hold this
camera the video was hilarious
Oh God never actually test this before
what in our pool bar we have the largest
barbecue that we could possibly find is
when we throw a party we want to be able
to do 50 burgers at a time
grab Janet I want to see she'll fit on
this I think you should be in the
suitcase real facts right back yep and
it's a rotisserie - so is that more of
it you're seeing as I'm config on a row
no no I it's a big ol it's a big old
grill and the nice thing - we can flip
this course and serve everyone right
from the pool we have seats in the pool
even a little bit of outdoor space make
it as comfortable as the inside so you
want to spend time out there year round
that's the huge thing for Kwan right now
so you can have some
don't have that you can add square
footage to your house just in your
outdoor area just making it comfortable
like Jonathan was saying if you're
lounging here or in the pool or even up
top we can even open up the back wall
the house is collapsible window wall so
we can open that right up and have a
nice unobstructed view of the movie
theater screen 15-foot movie screen this
is the way to watch any movie at night
and you can see that one of the light
pictures opens there every yard needs to
have the four p's cutting okay pool
ping-pong abuse and puppies there I was
gonna try make up the fourth but is this
the puppy fence that's the puppy fence
yeah it's very important that is a good
puppy fence is it a little family
get-together we have a small grill I
could put in there in this movie and
then this our outdoor dining area if you
see over there that's my ping pong area
table to malaria this is a nice Larry
for lounging but if you have a smaller
outdoor space I have the cutest area to
show you that would be perfect for what
you could do in your space it's
important for anyone who likes clothes I
know you're a fashionable lady to have a
closet that works for you so this is
something we did not show on our
property brothers at home renovation I
did this actually a couple weeks after
we finished the main right oh my old
closet only went this far it was about
four feet and I blew out the back wall
the tandem garage and I stole 17 feet
this looks great though yeah a nice
little added design I have a lot I have
a hundred and eighty pairs of shoes oh
my goodness I don't even have everything
in here my girlfriend gets this section
and I get everything else yeah my closet
definitely that's gonna be the real
issue I think closet organizers yeah
it's the full height get up there so I
mean a ladder is needed for the upper
parts but the thing is if you have
decent height in your ceilings even if
you only have a standard nine foot or
something like that utilize the height
because you can fit way more stuff in
there yeah yes these are my favorite
shoes by the way these are some
old-school
Nikes and my girlfriend customized them
and she actually did the artwork on them
is my old my old Jordans
little preview inspired for Europe my
girlfriend and I love Paris and you see
all the little cobblestone cafes and
whatnot so we did all the paving stones
in here we custom-made all the cushions
for all the benches in the table a
little bit of greenery and then we found
this big old door it's a real old door
it was actually at a junkyard it's going
to be tossed away and we decided to take
it 200 bucks
throw it up on the line it was being
thrown out so we bought it for 200 bucks
and it is awesome how do you find people
to do custom thing this is the question
I mean I do a lot of googling and I'm
like cool do you are a good Google Iser
you know where to look and also
relationships we've been doing
renovations and and custom pieces for
years and years and years so you start
to build up a big library of people
leave a lot of it's pretty easy so like
the cushions out here we put new cut
cushions in and that's just a seamstress
why usually no human curtains it's
really really cute like this so this
whole set here's these two chairs in
this table again it was being thrown out
by somebody all of the wood was worked
up and it was bent and the frame it was
this old rusty kind of white frame so
all I did fit it myself just sanded it
down
painted it with a rust covering paint
and then rebuilt 'add some of the wood
slats down and then it worked perfect
but anyway that is that is our place
that hope that inspires your design your
renovation in LA I think we need to get
to some baking we do guys I'm so excited
for you to see the videos they'll be
rolling out sometime this year we'll let
you know don't worry and you guys just
started kind of like really ramping up
doing the YouTube stuff - so how's that
been working out yeah we're loving it I
mean the scupper others that's our
channel so if you want to subscribe we
just want to show you guys fun fun
videos we come from a comedy background
so the fact that we can do more
community content is is great - and
collaborations like the kitchen okay
good
get ready guys look at Gracie look how
sweet she is happy girl I know honey
Peggy kisses you kisses smell potty Oh
kiss little tongue oh she's making
little noises in my ears these are all
they're like holiday and Halloween
costumes
we're basically shooting a bunch of like
holiday sort of themed videos you guys
will see a bunch of these throughout the
year which is kind of exciting we're
shooting it now spoiler alert a lot of
fun a lot of the holidays Christmas and
Halloween why would you want to get all
in the spirit in the middle of summer
it's true especially middle of summer in
Vegas what's your snapchat filter say it
was like 103 degrees three degrees
Fahrenheit
you know bump and grind
he actually lyrics Santa's work oh it's
August shooting Christmas videos
pre-emptive Christmas worker it's all
that jelly got there guys made it back
where he is working - oh ho yeah I can
do who do you think I'm talking to hey
lock your doors
how do you feel about french fries some
Aaron and put on some peeps and then I
think I'm ready to go - of the egg and
cheese sandwiches incredible day well
thank you so much for watching our day
we have so much fun with Scott brothers
go check out their YouTube channel cuz
they're gonna be posting a bunch of our
videos and we're losing a bunch of
videos from them in the future we had a
really good time that's great I mean
that's alright you
Oh such an egg on my body yeah hey guys
let's say two handfuls of strawberries
should be a little more precise